[Music]
i heard it's over there is that the
right direction i think so yeah
excellent thank you much perfect so we
get some ice cream after
excuse me sorry trouble you i'm just
wondering you know what the ice cream
shop is
have you ever experienced something that
you could have sworn
already happened think you've seen this
episode
already wait a minute did i already ask
that
well you might be experiencing the
mysterious phenomenon
of deja vu while deja vu
feels like a memory to us is
there any way we could control it
what happens in the brain when we
experience
deja vu why
is the phenomenon so common in people
with epilepsy
[Music]
and could deja vu mean we see the future
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you could control deja vu
you might think that deja vu is a glitch
in the matrix
well in some ways it is but instead of
computer code
your brain's electrical signals are the
source of the glitch
as cognitive psychologist dr ann cleary
mentions in her ted talk
certain groups of people with
neurological conditions
experience deja vu more than others
people with temporal lobe epilepsy often
experience
a flurry of electrical signals in the
memory centers of the brain
for many people with this condition deja
vu
is often a warning sign of a seizure
but don't worry it's also a sign
of a healthy brain do you ever have deja
vu mrs lancaster
i don't think so but i could check with
the kitchen so how do we
actually know if what we're remembering
is real or just deja vu
[Music]
according to adam zeeman a clinical
neurologist at the university of exeter
in the uk
it looks like a healthy brain
experiences deja vu
in the same way as someone with epilepsy
about two-thirds of people experience
deja vu
in their lifetime if you travel or
feel tired and stressed a lot you're
more likely to start
misremembering things fatigue and stress
can strain your temporal lobe the area
of the brain where memories
form and traveling will give you an
abundance of experiences that your brain
can misinterpret
as real memories whoa
i could have sworn i've tasted this
cheese before
alright it was at that fromagerie i went
to
in france
people who remember their dreams are
also more prone to deja vu
so if you're eager to experience this
weird phenomenon
maybe keep a dream journal or if all
else fails
you could medically trigger deja vu
through electrodes in the medial
temporal lobe
but that might be a little extreme
it's believed that some areas of the
temporal lobe
contribute to the feeling of familiarity
but i'm pretty sure i already knew that
chris mullen a cognitive
neuropsychologist and
leading researcher of deja vu believes
that
other areas of the brain are involved as
well
he suggests that we become aware of a
memory being
false in the prefrontal cortex
but what if these so-called
false memories are glimpses of the
future
can we remember something before it
happens
a research study conducted by dr ann
cleary of colorado state university
found
that participants felt like they could
see the future
while experiencing deja vu some people
even believe that deja vu is a way of
remembering a past
life but what if we're
thinking of a similar experience that we
already had
likely our brains are experiencing the
familiarity of
some scrambled memory so
if you're sure you've met someone before
well
they might just look like someone you've
seen in a movie
or quite literally the man of your
dreams
[Applause]
if you own and run a business like we do
here at under known
sometimes you just can't rely on your
memory
what am i doing in the living room i'm
supposed to be running a company
luckily with netsuite you can stay
organized and keep track of
everything all in one place netsuite
gives you visibility and control over
your financials
hr inventory ecommerce and more
everything you need all in one place
instantaneously
if you feel like spreadsheets or
quickbooks are slowing you down then
netsuite by oracle is for you as the
world's number one cloud business system
netsuite is used by over 24 000
companies
let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business
with a free product tour at netsuite.com
what if okay
if you're still convinced that you
remember
moments in the future precognition is
just science fiction as far as we know
an 80 year old man with alzheimer's
disease had
such an extreme case of deja vu that he
claimed to remember
everything it was so striking that
he refused to watch television or read
the news
everything felt like a rerun to him
however this is a pretty rare case
deja vu usually peaks in young adulthood
around
the ages of 15 to 25 it
then gradually goes away with age
if you're afraid you're experiencing too
much deja vu well
consider getting eight hours of sleep
every night cutting down on caffeine and
take up relaxing activities like yoga or
tai chi if it's more than a few times a
month well
you might want to see a doctor even if
you think you've already seen one
although these days we have a fairly
good scientific understanding of deja vu
there's still a lot we don't know
if you genuinely feel like you're stuck
in a time loop
well don't worry that's a story
for another what if
[Music]
you